[Music]
i'd like to start off with
the beginning where
it's the early 20th century and we have
cfcs
uh
chlorofluorocarbons which is a difficult
word to say um
and they're in
quite a lot of our manufacturing and
commercial goods so i'm curious if you
could start there by just explaining um
what cfcs are and what their role was in
the early 20th century
well they weren't actually
discovered until i think around the 20s
if i recall maybe stephen can correct me
on that but
they were
initially used
in
air conditioning so that was
a great advance over using things like
ammonia which is toxic and explosive and
all kinds of horrible things and the
great thing about the cfcs is that
they're non-toxic at least when you
breathe them although they're very toxic
to the ozone layer they're not toxic to
you directly
and they became really widespread you in
use though when they began to be used as
spray cans in aerosol propellants and
that didn't really happen until somewhat
later
i think that the spray can business
really started exploding
uh in the
in the post-world war ii era probably in
the 50s and 60s
uh and then it was discovered that these
things have very long lifetimes in the
atmosphere they live depending on which
one you talk about for some 50 to 100
years
so that is just staggering because what
it means is that
every year whatever we put in almost all
of it will still be there the next year
and it'll just pile up and pile up and
pile up so initially a few people who
worked on it thought hey this is great
it's a terrific tracer for atmospheric
motion how cool is that
but it turned out that although that's
somewhat true in the lower atmosphere in
the upper atmosphere they actually break
down make chlorine atoms and those
chlorine atoms can go on to
destroy ozone and and we first became
aware of this through some wonderful
work by molina and roland in the mid 70s
which later won the the nobel prize for
uh chemistry along with paul kreutzen i
could circle back on a little of the
details of the technology
if you'd like
sure go for it steve
the year was in the 20s 1929
and it was invented by thomas midgley
who was working for
frigidaire division of general motors
and just as
susan said this was viewed as a wonder
chemical because the chemicals at that
time were things like methylene chloride
and ammonia and even gasoline as a
refrigerant so it was very dangerous
there were lots of injuries
by that time america's waters were
polluted so it was difficult to use ice
from ponds
and so it was immediately commercialized
to replace these flammable and toxic
refrigerants and then just as susan said
uh
the companies that produced it slowly
looked at other markets aerosols
starting with pesticides for soldiers in
world war ii
and then finding a commercial market and
then solvents
because it's a very effective solvent
for electronics
and aerospace and then there were
other uses that came along such as
making rigid and flexible foam
and then finally towards the end there
were elegant uses such as hospital
sterilization and as the aerosol for
meter dose inhalers that are used for
asthma patients so it had
extraordinary uses and it was not
appreciated
until 1974 when
mario molina and sherry rowland
discovered that these chemicals could
just destroy the ozone layer before we
get to molina and roland i was curious
if we could actually start with james
lovelock
because
you know we're releasing and creating
all of these cfcs
and
it seems like he's the first person who
actually takes a look at
at these things in the atmosphere so
could you explain james lovelock's role
in this story
sure he invented the gas chromatograph
and made a lot of money off of it and
became independently wealthy because
it's a very
useful instrument for measuring all
kinds of things and he took it on a he
was british and he took it on a british
research vessel and sailed from the
northern hemisphere down to almost the
antarctic and showed that he could
understand exactly what the distribution
of the cfc that he was measuring
was based on the amount that had been
uh emitted
and he said oh isn't that cool it's a
great tracer for atmospheric motion as i
mentioned before
so um and in fact i'm pretty sure in in
his paper there's some kind of sentence
like this couldn't ever conceivably pose
any hazard because it's so non-toxic
um but of course
having less of an ozone layer is not
good for life on the planet because
ozone absorbs ultraviolet light that
is very very important for protecting us
from
sunburn and cataracts and protecting
animals and plants and all kinds of
things so depletion of the ozone layer
is actually a threat to both humanity
and the planet
i do want to say it wasn't until
somewhat later
1985
when scientists from the british
antarctic survey actually discovered the
ozone hole
and what they were doing was measuring
total ozone in the antarctic they'd been
doing it since the
1950s and they were able to show that
sometime around the late 70s it started
dropping like a rock way more ozone
depletion than molina and roland had
ever imagined
so it turns out that these chloroflora
chemicals are actually even more
damaging to the ozone layer in the
antarctic
and actually
also to some extent at mid-latitudes as
we now know
um than than we originally thought so
it's been sort of a cautionary tale of
don't be too sanguine about any chemical
made in the lab you know when you make
something in the lab that nature doesn't
make i think you should always do a
double take especially if it has a very
long atmospheric lifetime and and builds
up in the way that i described so you
that means you can't get rid of it if
you stop
uh using it you can't eventually but
it's going to take a long time for the
atmosphere to cleanse itself
could you explain why why james lovelock
was initially interested in in cfcs and
you know what his investigation led to
scientifically
as far as i know he really just wanted
to
see what their distribution was like to
get some sort of handle
on what they might be
what his instrument might be useful for
i don't actually know of a use beyond
that do you stephen
no i think that's right he was looking
for
gases that were indicators as you
suggest and of course he had a device
that would measure
other chemicals but i think he was
immediately struck by the fact that he
was seeing the same chemical at all
locations that he sampled
and then he made the natural connection
of saying where did this
chemical originate and how long did it
take to mix
in the lower atmosphere so i think it
was a a good solid scientific inquiry
of a very intelligent person with a new
instrument
maybe we should clarify i said uh he
went all the way down almost to the
antarctic but i neglected to underscore
that of course there is no
chlorofluorocarbon emission in the
antarctic right i mean at that time
there was nobody even there were no
stations there was nobody there
so
any chlorofluorocarbon that could get
there had to have gotten there by
atmospheric transport and it would also
tell you that it has to have a fairly
long lifetime because you know if you
emit um oh let's just say sulfur dioxide
from a power plant in the ohio valley
yeah i mean it's a serious issue it can
cost it can cause acid rain it can cause
little particles that are bad for your
lungs it does a lot of bad things but
it's not going to be found in the
antarctic
it you know it just doesn't have that
long of a lifetime it rains out so this
proved that they were a great tracer in
his mind i think that's that's what he
was attracted by
we're in this world where cfcs are
basically being used for a ton of
different applications um our current
understanding at that time was that they
were non-reactive and non-toxic so
basically a wonder a wonder chemical
that could be used for all sorts of
things and was much safer than the kinds
of chemicals that were using at the same
time
and here comes uh james lovelock who
um
from my reading it seemed like he first
got interested in it because
his view from his house was hazy and he
didn't know why it was hazy and he
wanted to figure out if it like if it
were uh
uh
man-made chemical chemicals or you know
what this pollution that was obscuring
his vision
was
um and so he starts measuring all these
cfcs everywhere um
and
now we're in a world where it seems very
clear that the cfcs are abundant in the
the lower atmosphere so
let's start to pivot into um mario
molina and frank rowland's role in this
story and how we begin to move from
noticing that there are so many cfcs in
the atmosphere to finding out that there
might be a problem
i will say that
dr roland has passed away unfortunately
so is molina
more recently but
he never went by frank he went by sherry
his name was indeed f
sherwood rowland but he was known to
everyone as sherry rowland
so go ahead steve do you want to take
this one yeah sure the story of it is
is actually another great science story
mario molina had finished his doctor's
degree at university of california
berkeley and had taken a post-doctorate
study with sherry rowland at university
of california irvine and they looked at
four or five
interesting topics and i think that the
history is that molina saw this one as
been particularly intriguing even though
it was slightly outside either of their
expertise
so it was a stretch for them but it gave
them a chance to look at something that
could be potentially
very important important and then the
story is that as they began to
investigate it started to seem
more and more obvious to them
and it became
uh a rush uh
for a conclusion because they were
worried about the effect of their work
uh there's one story that
sherry roland tells that he was he came
home from work one day
and his wife joan asked how did your day
go how was your work
and he replied something like well the
work is fantastic
but i think the earth is ending
so it was you can imagine
uh the tension created tension
and then they published their article in
i think in april
of 1974
and there was no uptake by the press
there was no
scientific confirmation it was a quiet
time
until that fall the natural resources
defense council nrdc saw this the
scientists there and recognized this was
a big public policy issue
so at the american chemical society fall
meeting
they had a presentation by merlina and
roland
and then by the best of good luck of
ruthless corporate behavior the industry
attacked them
and made the scientific study newsworthy
so this was a tremendous good fortune
oddly enough because then all the press
was asking
what are you talking about why is it
important and what could happen
and that cultivated in melina and roland
the ambition and and sherry roland
called for a ban on aerosol cosmetic
products hairspray
and deodorants and so this was stepping
out of the role
of a normal scientist and becoming an
activist
and of course there was a boycott
that was quite spectacularly successful
in the united states and then some
product bans
and i actually i just want to say i
think we should be proud in the u.s that
there was a consumer boycott i mean
people turned away from spray cans and
that actually interestingly enough did
not happen in europe
they kept using them so we we can look
back on that time as one in which people
were environmentally very aware in this
country
not just on the issue of
the ozone layer but but also for things
like photo you know like smog
and
clean water all those issues had
attracted a lot of attention right
around this time
i i will uh also say that it's
interesting that the at the time of the
moline and roland work they were talking
about the fact that from the best of our
understanding of the day
in 100 years we might see a few percent
decrease in the total amount of ozone so
kind of a small effect far in the future
kind of like the way some people used to
talk about climate change until maybe
this year or the last few
and
the antarctic ozone hole was a huge
wake-up call because what they found
was that ozone had dropped by more than
30 percent over antarctica already by
1985 something that no one had
anticipated so it was a huge shock to
the science community and at first a
fair number of people didn't really take
it seriously i can remember being in
scientific meetings with people who said
ah that british group they must just be
wrong
i won't say who they were
but you know it of course turned out
that they weren't wrong they were
confirmed quickly by other stations in
the antarctic and also by satellite data
and we now understand the chemistry that
actually made the chlorofluorocarbons
even more damaging than we thought they
would be
much much better than we did before
could you explain a little bit of the
the scientific uh mystery and uh the the
scientific inquiry that molina and
roland were engaged in um the kinds of
hypotheses that that they had and um
you know the the steps from going from
okay there are lots of cfcs in the lower
atmosphere to
uh eventually understanding the uh
chemical pathways
in their
role in ozone depletion
the big issue that they had to deal with
was
how do these these compounds get
destroyed and what is their atmospheric
lifetime
and they actually went into the
laboratory themselves to
try to make measurements relating to
that
so
they were
able to show
i think through the measurements they
made that the cfcs didn't react with
they didn't rain out that they weren't
water soluble so that was not an issue
that they didn't react with sand there
was some idea that somebody had
suggested that they would be destroyed
on the sands of the sahara and that
turned out of course not to be true
and uh but and then they looked at the
way in which they would break down what
would happen to them then i mean if they
have no way to break down in the lower
atmosphere the only place for them to go
is up up up up and as you go up you
reach much more energetic sunlight the
higher you go i mean obviously if you're
in the limits of space you're getting
the direct light from the full spectrum
of what the sun can put out but if
you're down on the ground you've got a
lot of atmospheric attenuation so
they began to realize that once these
molecules got into the stratosphere that
they would eventually break down make
chlorine atoms
and it was known already that those
chlorine atoms could go on to react with
ozone and
and then
there's a
another process which i'm not going to
go into uh that actually leads uh to a
catalytic cycle that destroys ozone
pretty effectively and that process was
already known from other work could you
actually say a word or two about that
because i actually think it's
interesting um the yeah the
yeah how a single chlorine atom can
destroy so much ozone
sure um
the chlorine atom reacts with ozone that
makes chlorine monoxide plus o2
now if that was all there was it would
be a one-way process you could never
deplete more ozone than the chlorine
that you put in but what happens is that
the chlorine monoxide can
react with atomic oxygen
for example so there's
if you go up into the well in the lower
atmosphere most of the oxygen as we know
is in the form of o2 right
so it's the oxygen that we breathe is o2
that's actually true as far as total
oxygen pretty much all the way up but as
you get up into the stratosphere
oxygen actually also encounters that
high energy ultraviolet light which
breaks it down and makes atomic oxygen
and ozone can also be broken down by
high energy light and that makes atomic
oxygen ozone is o3
so basically what first happens is the
o2
breaks down with ultraviolet light
making atomic oxygen the atomic oxygen
reacts with another o2 to make ozone
but then the ozone let's say photolyzes
to make o
so now if the o comes along and reacts
with the clo
making chlorine atoms again
plus o2
you've liberated the chlorine atom it
can go right back around and do it over
and over and over and over
and the reason that's actually happening
in the stratosphere it's in the sunlit
atmosphere ozone and atomic oxygen
are
exchanging with each other really
quickly so there's always some of both
present any time the sun is lit so i
mean at night the o goes away but during
the day there's ozone
breaks up with sunlight enough to make
some o
so you can just drive this catalytic
cycle over and over again and you can
destroy hundreds of thousands of ozone
molecules with one chlorine molecule
chlorine atom from a cfc molecule
in the time scale that the stuff is in
the stratosphere right and so i think
the the little bit of information about
that is that the is the chloro
uh in the chlorofluorocarbon meaning
that means chlorine right so there's
these chlorine atoms that are getting
chopped off of them
and then once they're free in the
atmosphere they can
be used to
basically slice many ozone
molecules and the ozone molecules are
heavier and more dense and so reflect
more
uv light
no no no no no density has and heaviness
has nothing to do with it uh the ozone
molecule is just capable of absorbing
certain wavelengths of ultraviolet light
that no other molecule can in our
atmosphere to any appreciable extent
that's why it's so important to life on
the planet surface
it's just a really good light absorber
at certain wavelengths
okay and so um
at this point um for
mario molina and sorry it's sherry
roland yes and so for both of them this
is still um
uh
theoretical or like model based work
right it hasn't there hasn't been any
empirical
verification of this
that's right
so
could you explain then how we move from
these uh
lab-based models to actual
empirical evidence of
you know these reactions happening and i
guess starting with where robert watson
fits in
bob watson was a chemical kineticist
originally and actually had measured
some of the reactions that we've just
been talking about in the laboratory so
what people do is they go in the lab i
should have said this earlier they go in
the lab and they uh evaluate how fast
individual chemical processes can happen
it's really very elegant work in flow
tubes and lasers and all that kind of
stuff
and it's uh
something that
watson was was known for but he got an
opportunity to become
a
a
leader of a research program in at nasa
which he took up and
he became very much a leader in the
community as far as both organizing
missions field missions to go out there
and look at things uh
in real time and more importantly
perhaps
a huge leader in the assessment process
which brought the scientists and the
policy makers together
i think that you can
really look at bob as a as a tremendous
founder of uh the
the whole way that we do scientific
assessment together with a gentleman
named bert bolin
who uh who has passed away unfortunately
after watson
um could you then bring in um how uh joe
uh joe joe farman fits in
yeah joe farman led the british group
that discovered the ozone hole as i
mentioned earlier
so they
noticed that their
ozone over their station at halley
antarctica
just seemed to be
decreasing at an alarming rate
and they checked it with another station
that they have which is at a slightly
higher latitude not quite as far to the
pole
so i'm going to say i should have said
i guess lower latitude
anyway 65 south is where the other
station is i think haley is about 73
south um might be 78
and uh they um
found that there was
ozone being lost at the other station
too just not as much and
that's when they decided that they just
had to publish so they did and it
attracted my attention along with the
attention of a lot of people i started
working on what chemistry could possibly
cause this and what i came up with was
that hey maybe and we knew that there
was no ozone hole over the arctic we
knew it was only over the antarctic
um you know because we had measurements
from places like sweden and norway and
um you know if any in canada if anything
was happening it was nothing like the
antarctic
uh so
measurements in other places showed ups
and downs you know variability from year
to year but they weren't showing any
kind of trend at that point they later
did and we can talk about that but we're
talking 1985 here so really early
i was a young scientist i was 29 at the
time and i decided that i was going to
try to take my photochemical model and
beat on it and pound on it and make it
stand on its head until it produces its
own hole
and uh so i did that and i figured out
that the reason that it was happening
was because antarctica really is the
coldest place on earth and it's so cold
that clouds form in the antarctic
stratosphere the stratosphere is very
dry so normally there just aren't any
clouds but down in the antarctic because
it's so cold the
vapors
mainly water vapor but also actually
nitric acid and other things can
condense
and
form these incredible polar stratosphere
clouds and the clouds
completely change the chemistry we can
talk about that but i think i've maybe
gone on too long with my enthusiasm for
which i apologize no no no this is uh
this is such an important and
interesting part of the story so um the
reason why the ozone hole
is
you essentially discovered why the ozone
hole is where it is
let me just say one thing before we go
back to the ozone hole one of the
interesting things that happened was of
course
barman and his research group declared
that there was the serious depletion
happened in antarctica so all the
scientists that had been building the
case with sherry roland
and with mario molina instantly jumped
on it in the press and in fact it was
sherry rowland that coined the phrase
ozone hole he was the first person to
utter that phrase
and that was also a very good case that
the public could grasp that they could
look at the nasa graphics they could
talk to scientists and so there was
really a great expectation that someday
there would be the smoking gun like this
an antarctic ozone hole or other
evidence and people were ready
uh and prepared to go to the press and
go to the public and in fact the
politicians by this time had been
briefed a lot and at the united nations
they've been working on this since
uh 1970 when they organized a working
group on stratospheric ozone depletion
so this great scientist
and great science was welcomed into the
community and they took full advantage
of this and then other great scientists
like susan jumped on it to say well how
can we go beyond the simple finding
of the ozone depletion and track it back
to its origin the cfcs and the other
ozone depleting substances
so it was science and politics
at its best
yeah i guess i i also want to say that i
didn't uh assume that the ozone hole was
necessarily due to chlorofluorocarbons i
tried to produce it all kind of ways
with uh
reactive nitrogen from
the aurora with dynamical changes i just
couldn't get it to happen any other way
and what we knew already and again i
think
it's it's a real achievement was that
people had been
interested in the idea of reactions on
surfaces for a while
but mainly because they thought they
were
perhaps interfering
with the measurements they were trying
to make in those flow tubes so the flow
tube is basically just a glass tube
and people
assumed that there was no surface
chemistry that could happen in the
stratosphere we know there is chemistry
on surfaces in the lower atmosphere in
the troposphere and it can be really
important acid rain is a great example
surfaces can make chemistry do things
that just doesn't happen in the gas
phase that's why you have a catalytic
converter in your car it's a surface
that converts the pollutants into
something else before it gets out the
the tailpipe
so surfaces lead to chemistry happening
very differently from gas phase and we
assumed the stratosphere was just gas
phase there couldn't possibly be any
surfaces
um but
interestingly we we sort of knew that
there were these polar stratosphere
clouds they'd been observed by explorers
going back you know i think 200 years in
the arctic and
120 or so in the antarctic so we knew
they were there
we just didn't really carefully evaluate
their chemistry but when people started
doing these experiments in the
laboratory
they thought certain processes were
actually going in the gas phase so they
saw for example
certain kinds of chlorine molecules
going away in their flow tubes and they
thought they discovered some new gas
phase chemistry turned out to be
something happening on the surface and
they said oh okay doesn't matter it's
just on the surface well it turned out
to be not just on the surface of the
flow tube but also on the surface of
those polar stratospheric clouds and
that's actually the connection that i
made i thought hey you know if this is
happening in the lab
there's no necessarily reason that it
couldn't also happen on polar
stratosphere clouds now that was
a
a leap that perhaps i shouldn't have
taken but uh but anyway i did
it's good that you did uh yeah could you
explain that that what that moment was
like more more so i mean that was
basically a key
super important scientific
discovery yeah i i had a very hard time
believing it when i when i you know this
was back in the days when uh when i was
running a computer model this was in the
days that uh
you would wait a long time for your
output because things were very very
slow
um i don't remember i don't think it was
still in the card you know computer
punch card day
i think i actually did have a file that
i submitted
um but the the wait for getting it back
i think
felt interminable and when i did
uh get the results back i was just
shocked to see
how ozone
behaved and one of the key things about
it is that it doesn't happen in the
winter in the dead of winter when the
polar regions are dark
this process won't won't be very
important
you have to have not only cold
temperatures so the polar stratospheric
clouds are there you also need sunlight
to drive certain parts of the chemistry
and i could go into the details of that
but i'm not sure you you need me to do
that it's uh it's a process then that
occurs in the antarctic spring
as it comes out of its long period of
dark cold winter it's still cold but the
sun starts coming back and that's the
combination that then drives the ozone
depletion and that that began to start
happening in my model
so i was pretty shocked it wasn't quite
for the right reason i have to admit
the
process that i had driving that that
final step of what i did identify
correctly was that the key reaction is
the hydrochloric acid and chlorine
nitrate from the chlorofluorocarbons
react together on the surface of the
polar stratosphere clouds they do not
react in the gas phase
we thought maybe they did it one time
but then we figured out it was just on
the surface of the float tube so we
forgot about it everybody
except until i remembered
and uh and then
the hydrochloric acid and chlorine
nitrate react on the surface of those
clouds that makes molecular chlorine cl2
which photolyzes breaks apart very
readily with sunlight that makes
chlorine atoms and now you're off and
running to produce ozone
depletion so
that part i i had all correct what i
thought was that the uh chlorine
monoxide might react with ho2 to close
the catalytic cycle
because you don't have much atomic
oxygen in the lower stratosphere where
the ozone hole was happening you need to
close that catalytic cycle we were
talking about earlier with something
else it turned out that really the key
thing is clo reacting with itself
to make something called a clo dimer
which then photolyzes
um but we didn't actually know that
chemistry yet we learned about it not
too long after that was discovered in
87.
i see so um so essentially there are
these these glass tubes and labs where
uh you know the scientists at the time
were trying to
basically create atmospheric conditions
in order to experimentally test the
models that they were generating for
what happens to ozone up in the
atmosphere and because it's a glass tube
there are you know surfaces there's a
lot of surface on it and so they were
discounting uh
you know what they were observing in
that glass tube because they were saying
you know the the upper atmosphere
doesn't have any surfaces so any
surface-related reactions don't really
make any sense
right that's basically it so you know
you were looking at that and you just
what was it like
what made you think that maybe there
were surfaces in the sky well i mean we
knew that polar stratospheric clouds
could happen in in the in the antarctic
and also in the arctic that that that
was
like i said people have visually you can
see them i've seen them myself they're
they're they're clouds they're actually
very beautiful they're they look like
they're they're almost a rainbowy kind
of appearance because the particles are
almost all one size and that creates a
a particular kind of beauty when the sun
hits it um but yeah i mean you can see
them they'd been seen
literally um there were also satellite
data and uh that had been published a
couple years earlier
and that helped to inspire me to think
about it but i actually knew about the
explorers
i was just intrigued by that kind of
stuff
so then
i was very excited to work with bob
watson when we formulated a mission to
go to the antarctic and to actually go
down there and make measurements that
might help to determine whether
reactions like that were hap were indeed
happening
and that happened in 1986
right so you you're creating these these
models that include the surface reaction
and so you've got this uh 1980s computer
that uh you're submitting this file to
um
and
you know
what do you get back from that model and
how does that motivate your expedition
uh to go then get measurements
uh
i if i remember i had it programmed to
make plots of the percent change in
ozone um and there was this
i didn't call it a hole at the time but
there was this uh
this area over the antarctic where once
i put those reactions in
i got a lot less ozone i recall
something like 30 percent less it's
published in my paper that i published
on this in 1986.
so i wrote it up and submitted it to
nature and
it was published in 86 and that was the
same year that a lot of us began
thinking about how to get down there and
test the different ideas that have been
put out because
the idea of
chemistry involving chlorofluorocarbons
was not the only idea out there
you know other people had
meteorological theories and
you know as i mentioned there was this
possibility that it might be solar
activity i guess somebody thought about
so you know
scientists are always stimulated to come
up with ideas um and we needed to get
down there and make the measurements
that could discriminate between the
different ideas so
i was uh very very fortunate to be young
and
able to get on an airplane and go to the
antarctic so i did in 1986 it was great
most incredible scientific experience in
my life actually
what what made it so incredible and and
what is it that you you saw what was you
know your favorite parts about your
expedition to the antarctic
well just going to the antarctic is an
unbelievable experience i mean you know
even if you just go on a cruise ship
it's uh it's it's like another planet
you know it is crystalline beautiful
unpolluted a pr uh full of
uh optical effects that are are just
amazing um and of course
brutally brutally cold we went down in
august of 1986.
when i got off the plane the temperature
was about minus 40 degrees celsius which
is also minus 40 degrees fahrenheit so i
like to joke that if you're around
jeopardy and the final jeopardy question
is at what temperature are celsius and
fahrenheit the same the answer is minus
40.
um but it was uh it was you know it i i
have been i'm originally from chicago
i've been in cold weather
um but i've never been in anything
colder than i think about minus 15
before
and
it was uh it's a shocker but after a
while after a couple of weeks
minus
15 actually feels very warm you really
do it's amazing how you acclimatize
everybody laughs steven's laughing as
i'm saying this but it's true it's true
really i i thought i would just kind of
curl up in my room the whole time but i
i didn't i i found that it was easy to
acclimatize the t-shirt
yeah really well actually people do
people actually even go jogging at uh
with shorts on at -15 yeah wow yeah
yeah it's incredible um depends on if
it's sunny or not the atmosphere is very
dry also down in the antarctic um
basically the cold has rung all the
paper out of the air
did you go jogging in your in your
shorts
no no i didn't do that but i'd certainly
remember feeling warm at -15 and you
know like opening up my jacket and stuff
like that and i definitely kept my
window open if it was -15
so um yeah i did i did um but
i made some measurements with my
colleagues
using
visible spectroscopy so we use the sun
or the moon or the sky as a light source
and we measured
chlorine dioxide which is a closely
related molecule to chlorine monoxide
and we were able to show particularly
with the moonlight measurements that the
values we found were you know
a hundred times more than they should
have been we
couldn't measure them anywhere else
because they were below our detection
limit but they were actually quite
measurable in the antarctic
so that was the key measurement that
that we made and it was an incredible
night the night that we actually did
that and then i think it was a next day
that i
made the data analysis and
there it was it was
it was an amazing amazing moment could
you explain more about how that
that particular data that you measured
fit into
the analysis and and what it proved and
you know the feelings and experience of
what it was like to finally have an
answer
first of all there's the getting of the
data which involves uh
putting mirrors up on the roof of a
little building in the antarctic
and directing the moonlight right down
into the instrument
and
doing that when it's cold and windy can
be a bit of a challenge so setting it up
for measurement is
physically challenging um
and
then
you know taking the data um
analyzing the data
i i was
i think careful enough to realize that
that wasn't going to be the only thing
it would take
to convince everyone that chlorine was
the cause of the ozone hole
the chlorine had to have come the
chlorine dioxide that we measured had to
have come from the chlorofluorocarbons
there was no other
even conceivable source for it and it
was a hundred times more of it than
there should have been and that's
because
it had gotten the the reactive species
and chlorine dioxide is is a reactive
form of chlorine
had gotten liberated from unreactive
forms of chlorine like hydrochloric acid
and chlorine nitrate which reacted on
the surfaces of those clouds and they
don't do that anywhere else so that's a
little more detail than i thought you
might have wanted but but that's why you
take these what we call reservoir
species for chlorine hydrochloric acid
and chlorine nitrate and you convert
them to active chlorine and now you're
really off and running for ozone
depletion and that's what happens on
those clouds
you're getting this this this data about
these particular chemical molecules and
then so you're the the
you know tell me a little bit more about
the the actual analysis and you know
what it's like being in the antarctic
feeling like you've you know you've
discovered why there is
a potentially world ending hole
well i will tell you this i i was really
careful i think maybe stephen can
correct me if he thinks i'm wrong but i
was pretty careful about not
broadcasting the news before we were
really really sure
so
the moon measurements alone were not
enough to convince me
and
one of the things that actually excited
me a lot was when we realized we could
also see this in the uh scattered
sunlight that we got if the sun was low
enough on the horizon there was even
enough chlorine dioxide to measure it
then
so what it is is a visible spectrograph
it's got a diode array in it like
actually very similar to the diet array
that reads the
prices when you go to the supermarket
today back in the 80s those were
incredibly expensive because they had
just been invented
and we had one that was cooled to very
cold temperatures to keep it from having
too much noise in it and we direct we
had a spectrograph which you can think
of as being sort of like uh a prism that
you
shine sunlight through and you separate
out the wavelengths of light the colors
of light come out as a you know as a
little rainbow that you see when you
when you put a crystal in front of a a
source of light
and so that's essentially what we're
doing we're putting a
a grating in this case a diffraction
grating
in the beam of the moonlight and we're
collecting the separated wavelengths of
light on our detector and we're looking
for the absorption
of atmospheric chemicals and we can
measure ozone that way we can measure
nitrogen dioxide at a different
wavelength but chlorine dioxide has a
particular band structure
in the visible that is what we measured
and we can also see it the fact that we
could also see it in the skylight and
that the difference between the skylight
and the moonlight was consistent with
what we expected from chemistry
and consistent with what you would need
to deplete the ozone layer got me pretty
excited
there was another group on our
expedition that measured chlorine
monoxide using a different method a
microwave emission technique which is
the same one that's used nowadays by
satellite
but in those days it was only used from
the ground
so and they also measured high levels of
chlorine monoxide and last but not least
i'll say that
the the following year in 1987
watson organized another mission which
actually flew on airplanes from
chile down to antarctica and measured
chlorine monoxide yet another way
by
a laser resonance fluorescence on board
an airplane that actually literally flew
right into the ozone hole so i would say
fair to say that from the science
community point of view
when all those measurements were in
people got pretty convinced but they
also had to be written up i mean it had
to be peer-reviewed before
something that important could really be
talked about as uh as a known piece of
science so i i was very cautious about
um spreading the word too early
so if you look at the history of the
montreal protocol
what you see is that in 1985 there was
something called the vienna convention
that was passed by the united nations it
had about
uh two dozen members signed it and this
is what's called a framework convention
that makes it possible to have something
like the montreal protocol
so that was in the spring of
1985 and shortly thereafter barman
published his article
which was a tremendous reinforcement
to the policy members that had
anticipated that soon there would be
evidence and that they needed to be
prepared
and then as we went into 1986 and susan
is doing
uh with her colleagues his brilliant
work in antarctica the preparations
underway for the montreal protocol
and the scientists were telling the
montreal protocol
that it could be another explanation for
the ozone hole so that you should hold
your fire until you're sure of the
results and you can find that in
lots of the accounts at the time
but by
the time of the meeting september of
1987
there was still a lot of uncertainty but
the policy makers were able to talk to
their national
scientists and others and felt confident
enough to go ahead and confirm the
montreal protocol so i would view it
from my point of view
of you and perspective that it was a
continuous improvement
in the science and the threshold of
belief
occurred for different people at
different times
but
you could then say of course there were
still skeptics in 1987 but it was my
experience that they were mostly gone by
1990 and so the work i was doing mostly
with corporations there was rarely a
meeting where there would be science
skeptics after 1990 that they were gone
from the earth that's moved on to
climate in fact so
so it was a tremendous contribution of
science and the other thing that's
important to realize is the industry
that use these chemicals
uh was not devoted to them they've been
reassured by dupont and others that they
were completely safe
and that there was no reason to worry
and then as soon as the antarctosano
came along they panicked and they rushed
to the market to find alternatives and
that's one of the reason the montreal
protocol happened so fast is the
industry in some ways was faster to
grasp the science than even the policy
makers stephen i'd love to bring you in
uh
i'd love to bring you in here uh to to
describe the um in particular you know
the transition from uh
the discovery the
the suvizin was involved in
um to the
to the montreal protocol so you know
what are the steps between the discovery
and the montreal protocol um and how do
we eventually get to um
the technology and economic assessment
panel uh that you co-founded
i'm glad to describe that it's exactly
what
what susan said is that there's a
laborious process to prove the science
and then there's another process to
communicate it and that's
partly what susan did and bob watson and
another scientist uh
uh dan albrighton and they were masters
of communication and there were lots of
meetings held between the scientists and
the diplomats but also the scientists
and the companies including
the national cat academy of engineering
did its own review of the science on
behalf of industry and came up with a
confirmation report i would call it no
new science a narrow view of science but
nonetheless it was the message coming
from the people they most respected and
sherry rowland was involved in that and
many many others so the communication
was very quick
and in fact i would say by january of
198
you could see big changes so the
protocols signed in september 87
in january of 88 there's a large
conference
and at that conference there were
several important announcements the most
spectacular was
that a t announced that they had found a
nature-based solvent
made from the terpenes from oranges and
lemons
and pine trees that could clean
half of the electronics equally or
better
than the cfc-113 are replaced and they
say that they said that transition
was technically possible within one year
so they went from skepticism
and standing back to becoming the
driving force
and it was also important because this
terpene
was not another synthetic chemical it
was naturally derived and harvested
from the disposal of the orange rhines
and the lemon rinds and then put to
positive purpose
so this was an eye-opener to a lot of
people that thought you had to have an
elaborate chemical to have an elegant
solution
and then at that same meeting
the auto industry stepped forward
and realized that most of the emissions
from car air conditioning was from
servicing and from leakage
and so for the first time they got
together
a partnership that developed commercial
recycling
for air conditioning they did that
within one year and the next year after
they
confirmed and approved the technology
they sold a billion dollars worth of
recycling equipment all across the world
so there's this enthusiasm of going from
panic that there would be high costs and
disruption to the enthusiasm of profits
and saving money
so it was
the science that drove us but it was the
technical innovation that did this
and then very shortly thereafter and in
an overlapping way
there were similar breakthroughs in foam
there was a commitment by the american
food packaging institute
to halt the use of cfcs in foam within
one year
and to switch away from all chlorinated
gases as quickly as possible
so we see this building momentum and
enthusiasm you have international
companies that are pledging to get out
and all the while
we haven't reached the montreal protocol
entering into force
because that occurs later after the
signing
and when it was signed and the first big
assessment which susan was involved in
as well
was done in 1989
and so this was an assessment that you
alluded to it included the scientific
assessment panel
it include included the
environmental effects assessment panel
and then it included the work on
technology and economics and this was
the idea of how do you make the best
available information
readily
absorbed by policymakers and business
community
but steve i would just add one thing
that you already said and that is it all
starts with people understanding the
problem
um you know you talked about the fact
that
people everywhere the public in all
around the world could look at these uh
satellite images of the ozone hole and
say hey you know that's actually pretty
scary stuff
um and
that created the will the political will
that generated the demand for all the
products that you've just described i
think without people understanding the
whole thing nothing happens personally
you're absolutely right and in fact in
the case of that food packaging it was a
school teacher in many in massachusetts
and her children in the class that wrote
to mcdonald's corporation and said
why are you destroying the ozone layer
so the people at mcdonald's
commissioned a survey
of their customers including children
and the customers responded they did not
want to destroy the ozone layer and it
made a big difference to where they
chose to eat
and in the case of mcdonald's children
drive parents to the restaurant the
parents say where do you want to go
today and they say mcdonald's
so it was a huge impact it was an eyes
open
business decision and they had announced
prior to the the packaging institute
changing that they were going to stop
the purchase
yeah they were putting hamburgers in
foam
uh clam shells and they switched over to
cardboard
which is fine because mcdonald's is so
delicious you eat it so fast anyway you
don't need the foam
that's right hot side hot cold side cold
was the slogan but this is this is
exactly right what susan's saying is you
have this circular effect where you have
the customers pushing the companies you
have the companies pushing their
suppliers and you have the policy makers
setting deadlines and pretty soon you've
got this wheel turning very fast
and as quickly as you catch up with the
available technology then you look to
the next strengthening of the montreal
protocol and that's what we saw
over the decades of the montreal
protocol more and more chemicals control
faster and faster phase out
stephen could you explain uh more
specifically what the montreal protocol
was and and and you know
who the key stakeholders were and
how it
came together and then was signed and
ratified and what that meant
so my role i was very fortunate because
i was hired by the epa in 1986
in preparation for the negotiations of
the montreal protocol
and i'm an economist by training and so
i had the highest interest
in showing that this was going to be
cost effective and feasible
and that the technology
would come together the mastermind
behind the montreal protocol was
the head of the united nations
environment
program dr mustafa tolba who was a
botanist himself and an accomplished
author and i think was very quick
at grasping this science so you have the
force of the united nations organizing
the meetings and then you have the
science that's providing the
justification for the treaty and then
you have leadership
countries that were advocates of a
treaty and that included
a group that was called the toronto
group because it was partly stationed in
toronto but that was the united states
canada norway denmark
many other countries uh sweden
uh that got together as a group and
helped craft the language that they
could sell to other countries
and so it was a masterfully designed
document in retrospect
and included in that document was the
idea
of start and strengthen
so if you look at it it only was two
chemicals cfc
and then a fire extinguishing agent
called halon
in the first negotiation in 1987 it was
just to freeze
the production of halon stop it from
growing and cut back cfcfc's 50
but that was not hard to do because 30
percent
was still
aerosol
and convenience cosmetic products
so it was a very conservative start
but the science was so persuasive in the
years ahead that they said to the to the
policies makers at the montreal protocol
that's not enough
you will not protect the ozone layer
with those two chemicals and you
certainly won't with those modest
reductions so then they added more cfcs
they added carbon tetrachloride methyl
chloroform
methyl bromide a litany of chemicals
were added and then each time
that they would meet every two or three
years they would have an acceleration of
the phase-out
so it was a very practical approach
that was done on an international basis
and one of the beauties of this treaty
is it includes incredibly strong trade
restrictions
so that if a country did not join the
montreal protocol they would lose access
to these ozone-depleting substances
even before the phase out
so it had lots of clever features and
lots of brilliant leadership and what
susan said about people mattering and it
they mattered a lot
over and over again and there were
two or three hundred people that had a
chance to become ozone champions and
make a real difference to the world
could you could you explain who the
who are the main
stakeholders involved in the montreal
protocol so was this mostly uh
you know
developed nations leading it or
that is a great question that's a
fantastic question that explains a lot
of why it was such a challenge so if you
look at the full set of chemicals
that are controlled by the montreal
protocol
they were divided into 240
separate sectors
so distinguishable industry groups that
had their own interests
in
keeping these chemicals or to phase them
out so if you look at those at some
other ones that susan meant mentioned
the air conditioning and refrigeration
and that includes industrial
refrigeration because many
chemical processes require that
and commercial refrigeration and also
what's called cold chain
the processing and the freezing and
refrigerating of food in order for it to
reach market so that alone would have
been daunting but in addition to that
there were these chemicals used as
solvents in aerospace
in electronics in the manufacture of
medical devices
it was used as a steroid and as i
mentioned is aerosol
for meter dose inhalers
it was used in fire fighting including
enclosed areas like on airplanes and
submarines and
ferries and ships and places that you
can't evacuate and then and if there's a
fire where you have to stay on board the
burning
vehicle so it was uh included uh all of
the nasa satellites in the
and the space labs and and the uh rocket
equipment manufacturer solid rocket
motor for the space shuttle required
methyl chloroform so you have these and
then there were laboratory usage so it's
used as a tracer gas as susan mentioned
but also it was used to have a dense gas
for a wind tunnel
and it was used for a pressure check
testing of scientific instruments to
make sure there were no leakages
of gases in or out so
as it got going also it was discovered
that
every weapon system
in every military organization
depended on ozone depleting substances
all the command centers were protected
with halon
all the ships tanks submarines
protected by halon
all the electronics and aerospace
manufactured and serviced
with cfcn methyl chloroform
all the gyroscope manufacturing for the
weapons guidance
whole list all the way down
all the optical readers all the a wax
everything that they could look at had
some use
and so it required the stakeholders to
look fundamentally at the basis of what
they were doing
and decide how do you shift
from using this chemical to a
performance standard that would allow
industry to compete
as how they could produce an alternative
that would be a pure replacement
and one measure that i think your your
listeners will find interesting is that
if you ask the public today or even the
affected industries
no one has stories of train wrecks
or disappointment
or failed systems because it was such so
successful most consumers would have
their entire house changed
and they would not notice this
the glues that are used to assemble
furniture were ozone depleting
substances
but people have not stopped buying
furniture
and so if you went back that's the
smallest list of uses
that found no substitutes so it's quite
remarkable
stephen so i i'd love it if you could uh
you know
you know you were on uh this panel um i
believe the the chair of it for for many
years um so i'm curious if you could
explain more so uh you know what that
experience was like what is it that you
necessarily did on the technology and
economic assessment panel and what the
impact of that was for
you know
implementing the
solution that was needed after
susan helped to
discover the mechanism of the problem
know thank you for asking me that
because that's what i'm most proud of of
course
uh
when i was appointed with vic buxton
from canada to set up the first
technical panel
we were like-minded and we had a great
idea and that was instead of casting out
for experts
from
various sources and seeking wide
participation and balance of interest we
didn't do that at all
we recruited the experts
from the organizations that were already
committed to protect the ozone layer
because these would be people motivated
to find a solution
rather than intellectually interested in
in describing solutions
or even worse be a stakeholder against
a new alternative and they would become
internal critics
so the notion was that you on a
technical committee you could not have
a better set of people
than the people whose success in their
enterprise
depends on finding alternatives and
realize that a team could find the
alternatives faster than others the
other secret of our success is we had
something called
self-affecting technical solutions
and so for example one of the chairs of
the of the halon committee studying
haewon was the chair
of the national fire protection
association that set the standards for
where halon is used
so as quickly as a use could be
eliminated with an alternative
he would go back to his committee and
decertify halon on that use
we had members of the coast guard
on the committee and as quickly as there
were alternatives on ships
they removed from the requirements
of the united nations maritime
organization the use of hawaii so it
went from
compelling the use for safety
to prohibiting the use
for environment
so it was this remarkable internal group
and if you go back also you'll notice
that some of the
most important technologies were
invented
by people that only met on the committee
for the first time so you had groups of
of uh military suppliers that got
together
and to tell the communication suppliers
and invented something called no clean
soldering that eliminated the use of
solvents and saved the ozone layer but
it also increased the reliability of the
products and they were
enthusiastic about commercialization to
the extent that they patented the
technology and then donated it to the
public domain so it could be used
anywhere in the world
at no expense to the user
so you have this enthusiastic group
of genius engineers working on a short
deadline and constantly resupplied with
motivation
from scientists like susan
because as fast as they would take
satisfaction and what they'd
accomplished they were being told it's
not enough
it's not enough to just do these
chemicals we have to do more it's not
enough to do these chemicals on the old
schedule we have to go faster so some of
these sectors halted their uses
uh years ahead of the deadlines of the
montreal protocol or the clean air act
it was
really quite inspirational and and most
of those people would tell you it was
the best part of their life because they
never would have been allowed to work
with the
engineers from the competing
corporations if it hadn't been for the
team drawing those together for public
purpose
so is a is a good way to characterize
this then that there's this huge set of
uh
of of compounds that when they get up in
the upper atmosphere they release
chlorine
and um the you know the chlorine is
really the the big issue and so um you
know these hydrochlorocarbons are being
used in so many applications um you've
described a lot of them and so the the
job of this committee is to
one uh you know
slowly
through regulation phase out
um
you know this long list
of uh ozone-depleting chemicals while
also generating uh alternatives to their
use that are
not ozone depleting
yeah that's right generating or
identifying and there's a a subtle uh
problem we face that's now being faced
again for climate and that is as susan
mentioned most of these chemicals have
long atmospheric lifetimes so when you
stop producing the cfc it can be a slow
decline
in the chlorine that's been contributed
to the stratosphere over many many years
others of the chemicals like methyl
chloroform and most of the hcfcs have
short lives and so any reductions you
make in these chemicals that do all
their damage within a short number of
years
has a bigger effect immediately than
doing the same amount of effort on one
of these other chemicals and what the
scientists were telling
the technical options committee and the
montreal protocol was that we had to
worry about the long run and the short
run
and so hcocs as refrigerants and foam
blowing agents were viewed as a
transitional substance so if you stopped
using cfc11 and you started using hcfc22
that was an improvement in bolt the gwp
and the forcing of
ozone depletion and the same thing for
methyl chloroform so the ambition
of the montreal protocol was to work
incredibly quickly to get rid of the
short term chemicals and uses within
alternatives that would be solvents for
example using metal chloroform but at
the same time allow some hcfcs so that
you didn't have to endure the continued
use of the cfcs and that was that was
the technical challenge to keep your eye
on the long run and at the same time
keep your eye on the short run and some
of the scientists
were all also over motivating that kind
of ambition because there was a concern
that we might go too far in sending
chlorine and bromine to the stratosphere
and do irreparable damage or damage that
would take much longer to solve
so true or not
it was highly motivational and it caused
a tremendous effort on our committees
first of all to get rid of methyl
chloroform if you look at the curve of
methyl chloroform and the overall ozone
uh protection it was a a critical first
step and it was accomplished
probably in two and a half years
worldwide
so let me uh toot steven's horn a little
bit and then also uh clarify one one
point i mean i think the
the invention of the technology and
economic assessment panel teep as we
call it of the montreal protocol was a
real master stroke because it brought
the
engineers and scientists from industry
into the process to help figure out what
could be done
and so the way the assessment process
worked is on a systematic basis the
science group that i was part of would
assess the science
steve's group would assess okay the
science says we got to phase these
things out what can we phase out what
what is
technically feasible
and we would provide these reports
uh along with the one from the impacts
panel that would say
you know if you keep doing this you're
going to have so many skin cancer cases
a year by 2050 and stuff like that all
three of those reports would be
explained to a group of policy makers in
a un meeting so the
uh
the decisions weren't actually made by
steve
but steve's group was highly highly
influential
in
educating the policymakers
and guiding them really um on what would
make the most sense what could be done
the most cost effectively the most
quickly etcetera etcetera and then they
made the decisions
but um the great thing about it is it
it's not a political group at all it's
we you know it's a in the old days we
would call them a bunch of guys with
slide rules and you know that included
the people who came from industry they
weren't the political leaders of those
companies they were they were the people
in the trenches
trying to actually figure out what to do
instead
and and that's what made it work so well
uh i really have often wished that we
had
a similar way of doing the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change
assessment process we have a science
panel that's pretty similar
but but we don't really have quite the
same technology panel and many people
have commented that the technology panel
that steve put together was
uh you know just huge in making the
montreal protocol work as well as it has
and the ozone layer is actually finally
beginning to heal
it's a real testimony to their success
yes stephen please i invite you to uh
toot your own horn a little bit more
here because your contribution was you
know extremely significant um
towards the
towards the elimination of the
the ozone hole um i have a fun fact here
uh that i that is from a paper of yours
um the so in 2007 um steven uh you
released a paper with velder's team
published the importance of the montreal
protocol in protecting climate
um
and
the team quantified the benefits of the
montreal protocol and found that it
helped present prevent 11 billion metric
tons of ca
equivalent emissions per year
and delayed the impacts of climate
change by 7 to 12 years so um
yeah please uh
you know what are some of your
favorite achievements and you know this
is something you're involved in for
decades
yeah that's a great story and of course
very glad to tell it uh one of the
things people know about me that have
worked with me for many years is i work
my slogans a lot
so i try to reduce my ambition to
something that's like a chant
or a short
instruction that i can give myself to
move ahead
and after years of working with susan
and many other scientists and mario
molina and sherry rowland and struggling
with these issues year after year after
year and waiting for the science to come
on board and there'd be a missing link
and there'd be something that was
misinterpreted and we'd have to go back
to square one i came up with the slogan
science
too important
to leave to chance
and what that meant was that it was my
job to say
what kind of information are the policy
members missing those are the people i
hang out with all the time because the
same time i was the deputy director for
stratospheric ozone protection at the
epa i was the liaison to the department
of defense on climate and ozone layer
protection so it's in those meetings
where people trying to decide
is it worth investing another millions
of dollars in this new technology or
should we do something else
so uh in working with citizen in 1995 on
a joint report between the ipcc
and the t
i realized that the montreal protocol
had done a lot for climate that wasn't
well appreciated over at the montreal
protocol
that this facts were available so i put
together what we called a dream team
which include goose builders who was the
lead author of brilliant scientists from
the netherlands it included david faye
who was one of colleagues of susan and
noah and john daniel
and then it included matt mcfarland
who's a scientist who was once at noaa
but worked the better part of his career
at dupont
and so we had it and then myself had
been on the tape for oh so many years
and at epa
so the idea of the team was to say
just how big
was the contribution of the montreal
protocol to protecting the climate and
how do we communicate that to the
montreal protocol so they would consider
that
as part of their obligation
and part of their legacy
because we were coming up my concern we
were coming up to a very long interval
of hcfc use that the montreal protocol
had plateaued its ambition
and they had accomplished so much they
were resting on their laurels and they
had lost this
impulse to get more stringent
so this committee was put together it
quickly
uh put together all the facts incredibly
complicated at the time although people
have done work like this since
confirming it and this dream team came
up with the conclusion that the montreal
protocol had already accomplished
more than the kyoto protocol could have
accomplished if every party every state
government in the world had joined kyoto
and if all of them had met its
obligations
so this was huge i mean it was shocking
to us it was shocking to the world we
brought it back the same year 1997
97
excuse me
uh 2007 to the montreal protocol
and that year they accelerated the hcfc
phase down
so it was a tremendous victory and it
was exactly what i would hope would
happen is if we assembled science
in a new way that was headline news
that the policy makers would get the
message and do something important
and then two years later the same team
decided well why don't we show the
montreal protocol
how important it could be
if the chemicals that replaced 15
of the ozone depleting
chemicals which are hfcs were phased
down under the montreal protocol ozone
saved chemicals controlled by the
montreal protocol
and that was accomplished in 2016 took a
decade
so
but we're very proud of ourselves and i
think it's a perfect example of the
advantage
of a group of people with a wide set of
skills working together including
somebody like me who's not a atmospheric
scientist working with atmospheric
scientists and making more clear
uh what the policy makers need to know
i'd love to i'd love to pivot in here
now and to you know extracting some of
these lessons that you're sharing
stephen for
how we might do better with modern
climate issues from greenhouse gases
and also other uh global catastrophic
risks um but you know i think that's a
you know
you guys have done an excellent job of
telling the story of the the science and
the discovery and then also the uh
strategic part and like the solution
making
of um
the story of the ozone hole um so
as we get to the end of that i'm curious
if you have any
thing else you'd like to wrap up on
about that story or you know what is a
what is a key insight or what is this
whole
you know when you look back at
everything that you've you know you've
contributed and been through what is it
that stands out to you
you know my theory of change i think is
the same as students that people matter
the most
that the ability to bring the right
people together at the right place with
the right instructions is bound to have
an important conclusion and one of the
things that i always found was if you
have the best engineers no matter what
their attitude if they have the goal
that is coincident of the environmental
protection they'll find a solution so i
think this
accumulating of the science and the
engineers and courting and coordinating
the activity these assessment panels are
just everything that if you do that you
can't help but be successful but the
other thing that i'm realizing now
is that you have when you're in a hurry
like we are for climate you have to take
advantage of the existing institutions
so as quickly as we added hfcs to the
montreal protocol i would like to add
other chemicals n2o nitrous oxide which
is an ozone depleting greenhouse gas
that was neglected by the montreal
protocol and then there's other gases
like methane that have nothing to do
with the sectors that are involved in
the montreal protocol but the framework
of the montreal protocol might be
perfect for a methane treaty so you
might have the montreal protocol people
help design a methane treaty
or
if the montreal protocol can find its
way
to create new capacity with new skill
sets you could have methane drawn into
the montreal protocol because it's
genius is partly that you turn off the
chemical at the source
and force all the downstream changes to
occur
and that's different than something like
epa where you often
find one part of the problem
catalytic converters and gasoline and
you implement that
but you're not focusing on the big
picture which is electrification of the
cars
and so there's there's this
inherent advantage of the montreal
protocol top down
turn off the chemical
bring on the technical information bring
people together for solutions
uh reinforce and reward so i could go on
for the longest time i'm very
enthusiastic about the success of the
montreal protocol i absolutely believe
the lessons could be taken up better
than they have been and i think if they
were taken up we'd be well on our way in
many other environmental problems
yeah i like to uh tell students in my
classes and i feel like i've learned
this over the years with montreal and
i've seen it in so many other problems
as well that there's three p's that
determine how well we do on any
environmental problem the first one is
personal is the issue personal to to to
me to us
uh and in the case of the ozone issue it
was deeply personal because skin cancer
i mean you know cancer doesn't get any
more personal than cancer right but but
also all the other
attendant things that it can do
the second p is perceptible is the issue
perceptible to me the best case is if i
can see it with my own eyes you know
like like smog um but you know seeing
the satellite images that we talked
about earlier you know that that was
good enough
uh to make it perceptible to a lot of
people and the third big p is are there
practical solutions
and that's where steven's
type of work has been so important so
when you think about climate change and
you think about the three ps
people haven't really considered it
personal until pretty recently because
it seemed like a future problem not a
today problem we can talk all we want to
about you know caring about our
grandchildren but you know really what
we care about is is us
right
so
um and we do care about our
grandchildren of course we do but not as
much as we care about us it's just a
fact i think
it's natural and normal we don't need to
be embarrassed about it
particularly when you're talking about a
future problem and you can always hope
that there'll be other solutions in
place by then so is it personal for a
long time we thought it wasn't is it
perceptible
for a long time we didn't feel like it
was
nowadays i would say more and more
people are recognizing it as personal
and perceptible the kinds of things that
have happened in the world this year
have just been
amazing in in being wake up calls
because so many places have flooded so
many places have had massive fire
these are all the sorts of issues that
we knew were happening so much erosion
is going on because of rising sea levels
people are just
and actually when people would say to me
well it's not really perceptible yet my
answer to that would be
yeah i know and it's a problem but you
know it's going to fix itself with time
and i think we're just about there it
has fixed itself and then there's that
big third p is are the solutions
practical and there's been a lot of
propaganda
you know out there saying
they solutions are not practical but i
think we're reaching the point now where
we recognize that they are
so i i think that we're really at a
turning point on climate change
i i'd love to pivot here more into
exploring uh lessons to extract for for
what we can do about climate change
and other global catastrophic risks for
you know the theory of change about what
we might do about those uh and i'm also
mindful of the uh the time here so if we
could hit on these a little bit faster
that would be be great um one thing i
don't
one thing i i don't think that or one
thing i would like to
hit on more clearly is um
what is the bad thing that would have
happened if um you know the work of you
stephen and the work of you susan um and
all the others who were involved in the
discovery and
you know solution towards the ozone hole
what is the bad thing that that would
have happened
um
you know if we had just continued to use
cfcs
there's a lot of work on that now people
call it the world avoided scenarios so
what world did we avoid well
by mid-century it would have been about
a degree hotter than it's actually going
to get so that's a degree celsius by the
way so instead of you know a degree from
a degree and a half from mainly co2 and
methane that we're trying to avoid we
would have an extra degree on top of
that from cfcs that we would have had to
avoid that's a big deal
something like 20 million skin cancer
cases in the united states sticks in my
mind by mid-century but
i would have to look check that number
by to to be absolutely sure
yes susan's absolutely right there's a
lot of skin cancer cataracts but one of
the things you can look at is you can
say two interesting things you could say
what if molina and roland had not had
this hypothesis and certainly you could
say well someone would eventually but if
it had been five years later or ten
years later it would have been
catastrophic because it did take time as
susan said it does take time to make a
hypothesis to confirm it to do the
ground measurements to do the aerial
flights and so forth so it was
just in time or a little bit too late
that it was really a tight schedule that
was working when you include diplomacy
and corporate changes and and all of
those things but you can also look and
say
what if the montreal protocol and
melania had been delayed some period of
time and what you can say is exactly
what susan said that the cfcs would have
grown in climate forcing let alone ozone
depletion to a level that would have
been untenable for earth that they could
have been almost the same level as the
co2 climate forcing so we were
incredibly fortunate to have this early
announcement it was incredibly
fortunate that the antarctic ozone hole
was noticed
finally and announced and it was such a
spectacular persuasion
and then fortunate that the montreal
protocol was able to take this and then
in a derivative that the corporations
were able to make the the reductions i
also think it's important to remember
that this really was a training ground
for a lot of people that scientists had
not worked together successfully on
assessments this large and so
continuously brilliant over so many
years
if you look back at each of the
assessment panels i find almost no valid
criticism of any of the findings at any
of the points in time that this was a
well-done process
actually stunning so
the world avoided uh if you read the
nobel
award for 1995 for crewson and molina
and roland it says that life on earth
would not have been possible as we know
it
if you read paul newman's report on
world avoided you find out that it would
have been untenable to go outside at
most latitudes for very long without sun
protection far beyond what people wear
when they go out today so it would have
been a lot of joy taken away a lot of
miserable misery brought on by
these medical effects and it would be a
less successful world because these
technologies that replace the ozone
depleting substances are purely superior
better energy efficiency
less toxic more durable
more easy to repair and reliable it's
quite a success story
so let's um
let's explore um
you know the these these peas as uh as
susan has put it um so we have the issue
of of uh greenhouse gases uh
warming the the climate today
um
and
a lot of
you know what you were involved in
steven was the economics of making
transitions so both
the innovation required to
replace hfcs and then also the questions
around that being economical
so this is you know the importance also
of
industry being
involved in the in the process
um
so
i i'm curious if you could explain um
[Music]
you know your experience with industry
and how difficult or easy it was
to get industry to make this transition
and how that compares to the transition
that
industry and governments need to make in
the modern day around climate change and
how much of that difference
you know
is a bit circumstantial around
the technologies and innovations that
need to be made
yeah that's a great question susan i i
think agree and i agree that
that some of the stakeholders on the
climate side
were more persistently ruthless than
we've experienced under the montreal
protocol the early days when molina and
roland came up with their announcement
it could not have been more ruthless
character assassination
they were lists of
uh people that were not to be hired uh
the regents of the university of
california prohibited sherry rowland for
applying to certain
organizations for funding and on and on
but if you look at what's been done by
the coal companies and petroleum
companies i think that that was orders
of magnitude wars over a longer period
of time including
interjecting a lot of wrong science over
and over again which was a terrible
distraction and also took a lot of
energy away so there's no doubt
about the differences of the two
but what i have found out working on
ozone layer as even sectors that have a
bad reputation for other topics can be
leaders on a topic
once motivated as susan solomon says and
come to believe what they're doing i
give an example
the automotive industry was among the
most rigorous in getting rid of their
solvent their foam uses
foams and cars include what are called
safety phones so that under the dash of
the car originally it was underneath the
surface of the fabric it was all ozone
depleting substances
it was all ozone depleting substances
for the refrigerant
for the solvent to make the components
for the electronics and so forth
but they
looked at the science they got motivated
and they
stopped using these chemicals as quickly
as the other sectors
so they were one of the one of the fast
to go so what my lesson is is you
shouldn't judge a book by the cover
you should not hold it against an
institution because they misbehave
in the past and you should give them a
chance to make a new start on leadership
right now
the other thing i would add is the
public right now
is much more engaged in climate than
they ever were in ozone layer protection
so if you go back there were very few
of the industry projects that had active
involvement
of non-government organizations
environmentalists
because it was being done so well by the
companies themselves that would have
been a futile use of those talents but
you look today there are thousands of
organizations
that are demanding changes in industry
they're in the streets they're
protesting
this did not happen for the ozone layer
it was the smallest amount of activity
so
there's uh the difficulty of the fossil
fuel industry but it's offset by the
ambition of the non-government
organizations and some of the
governments so
uh lots of things that are happening
there what would you add susan
well i think you summarized it pretty
well
i think the other thing i would add is
the engagement of young people today
they have
been
exercised and have become
pretty upset about the future that they
see themselves inheriting
greta tunberg has done a fantastic job i
think of
mobilizing
worldwide i in in a sense the ability to
get together on things like um you know
the tools that we now have with the
internet have allowed that to become an
international movement much more
effectively than we could have ever done
in the 80s for climate no matter how
concerned we were you know the telephone
only worked so fast so uh
you know i think you see a
public engagement on climate change that
is driving a lot of of what's going on
and having a huge influence
is is there anything that you
you know is there anything that you both
wish or would suggest
as
actions or um
you know things that are really
important for
the generation
you know
the generations that face climate change
you know what it is that
um they need to understand and do i mean
we're talking about making things a
practical personal and is the last p
perspective
personal
perceptible and practical yeah
and so there's still this i mean a large
problem also beyond um
these issues global catastrophic and
existential risk issues
beyond making them
personal
and there is certainly difficulty around
making
action around them practical
um
with the last pe for perceptible a lot
of people don't even agree about the
science
of climate change
um so i'm wondering if there's any
similarities between
that and what you experience with hfcs
and what you suggest there is to do
about that i mean because the climate
issue has become politicized certainly
yeah i mean i i would argue that it is
becoming perceptible i think most people
uh around the world have noticed that
the summers are hotter than they used to
be that heat waves are more extreme than
they used to be so
perceptible is not so much the problem
anymore i don't believe
um what what is the problem is the
practical that they believe that it
would cost too much and that it's not
practical to do it
um
that is increasingly becoming
less and less
tenable
when it comes to power plants for
example
is nowadays if you're going to build a
new one it is cheaper to do it with
solar and onshore wind than it is to do
it with either coal or gas
and so and and nuclear of course too are
more expensive so there's been a pivot
in the power industry to
uh to to renewables that's been very
rapid i think that uh we we need to
put a lot more investment into that
because it does take an upfront
investment it it's true that when it
came to some of the things we could do
for
the ozone layer a lot of them were
really uh
we were getting rid of things that we
didn't have a deep investment with i
mean you know how invested are you with
your can of spray deodorant in your
medicine cabinet probably not very you
know you can throw it away and and or
maybe you can even use it until it runs
out and then go out and buy roll on
right
but but probably a lot of people went
out and just bought the roll on because
they figured it was a very good thing to
do for the planet but so so this is
indeed a lot tougher because of our
investment in existing infrastructure
some of which is tremendously expensive
but i don't think there's any real
barrier to making the transition and as
soon as those things become as soon as
the alternatives become cheap enough
they essentially pay for themselves
because energy drives everything so if
we can make energy
more cheaply with solar and wind
then
the
cost of doing absolutely anything that
requires energy becomes automatically
cheaper too
and that that makes a sort of a snowball
effect of greater and greater demand we
need to make our grid more robust to
things like uh intermittency and able to
transmit
electricity over broader spatial ranges
that is doable it's not you know it's
other countries have already done it
actually so it's not something we
couldn't do
there's a lot of things that uh that are
beginning to really happen quite quickly
and i'm very optimistic we but we do
need some real changes in our existing
infrastructure there's no doubt about it
yeah so there's two things i would add
uh yeah the first thing is the united
states is now behind
the rest of the world on barrier removal
so in europe you can use technology
that's been in the market for five years
now absolutely proven safe and effective
energy efficient that's prohibited by
the us epa for use in the united states
so they are
a wall against new technology where they
used to be a door
and so somebody has to get in there and
motivate and get approval can you give
an example
example uh there's a refrigerant called
hfc 32 that has a third
of the
global warming potential it has 20
percent higher energy efficiency it's
mildly flammable but it hasn't been
improved in the united states similarly
there are natural refrigerants that have
not been improved and if you look at the
timeline another example which is
is easy to understand is they approved
years ago a decade or more ago a
chemical that has a gwp of less than one
to replace
hfc-134a which has a gwp of 1300
this was allowed for light trucks and
cars
but the industry at that time did not
apply for what's called
highway trucks the big trucks that move
cargo and off-road vehicles like farm
tractors and construction equipment
mining equipment forestry
and that the industry applied
months and months ago
to have this used on their equipment
there's no
difference
in using it on an off-road equipment or
an on-road equipment or a big truck or a
small truck because the cab of a big
truck is about the same size as the
interior of a car
but for some reason the epa has not
finished that process which is now way
beyond the statutory limit of time and
they say it's because they just haven't
had time to do it well this is not
acceptable you have to have government
moving at the pace of industry and then
the last thing incredibly important the
united states military and military
organizations all over the world were
part of protecting the ozone layer so
far that's not the case if you look at
insight at the documentation
of military organizations they say it's
a
force multiplier it makes everything
worse in national security they say it's
a
it's an amplifier of conflict there's
tremendous concern
about the displacement of populations
and immigrants across borders
and distractions from security because
you have to do humanitarian relief
that's all in the documentation but so
far all they do mostly is to do
resiliency of their own facilities so
they're doing what they need to do to
protect against the effects of climate
change but they haven't engaged yet
in stopping climate change which is much
more cost effective
the last thing you want to do is let
climate change happen and then try to
run away and hide and build against it
because that's brutally brutally
expensive so i think those two things if
we were more aggressive on approving new
technology and if we had the military
organizations involved as part of the
skill set and part of the solutions and
so forth i think we'd go a long way
as a final question here um
so stephen your your panel um the
technology and economic assessment panel
uh was super successful in this
strategic and coordination front on
the technology and the replacement of
the technology which is something you're
we're also just exploring does the does
the paris climate accord have anything
similar and do you see a panel like this
as being
something also that's crucial for
um
you know the climate change crisis and
also
the
you know the governance around other
global catastrophic and existential
risks
yeah i think you're right and susan and
i have both tried over many years
to get the climate convention to do
something like the t
uh recently i realized that if you don't
want to wait for the
for the ipcc to do this you could do it
as a shadow team
and that it's very easy i think for an
individual sector to organize itself
under the same principles of being
objective and including members
that have the coincidence of interest in
changing the market and changing the
technology you could put that together
within an industry and then bring
forward the solutions that you'd like to
see implemented and this is almost
happening in europe right now because
they're phasing down hfcs much faster
than the united states and they're doing
it on a sector by sector basis and
they're involved in the stakeholders and
the stakeholders have figured out that
if they come to the eu with a single
plan that cuts out their share of the
goal
the european union will approve that
if they come in with separate views and
lots of disagreement the eu will choose
their own plan for them
so they have two choices do it their way
or do it the government's way and so far
they always choose to do it the
practical
uh cost-effective
technology that they understand the best
and
that's exactly what the teep did so i'm
very enthusiastic about that model and
in fact
that's where if i were an industry
that's where i would
would put my money right now as i try to
say how do we become the leaders on this
so that these activists that can cause
mayhem in our company would say no use
messing with that company that susan and
steve runs let's go bother someone else
let's let them uh solve their problems
and we'll go on to a recalcitrant track
sector and to give them bloody hell
i think that's a very persuasive
argument
all right stephen and susan uh thank you
so much for coming on uh
if you have any
final words for the audience about
climate change the the ozone hole and
existential risk
here is a space for you to share it
well i hope we've given you some hope in
this uh in this period of of talking i
mean uh it's easy to become
kind of despondent about climate change
because you know
terrible events keep making people
suffer
day after day on the other hand i really
do believe there's light at the end of
the tunnel i think the ozone issue
demonstrates that and i think we we are
on the road to getting to uh to a
solution
i would just add to that that
organizations like
future of life institute or a tremendous
part of the solution i do believe that
recognition and explanation and
and
all of those things make a big
difference to getting people motivated
to take on this very hard work it's it's
work you love when it's over but it's
always hard while you're doing it so we
have to have the highest motivation
possible and you folks are part of that
solution
well thank you very much stephen and
susan for for coming on the podcast and
also for your scientific and strategic
coordinations to a
global risk in the
in in our lifetimes
thank you lucas
thank you very much
[Music]